This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听《艰难历程》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。这个节目探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在其他任何地方都觉得不太安全进行的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，倾听并学习。
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
以艰难的方式在AHA电台应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你曾两次篡改过这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我的天哪。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《爱情陷阱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临后果。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。2%。当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人数比例只有这么高。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些苦难，你将成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即TWO.%，可在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。
We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down, dive into, explore the psychology of our 20s. If you have ever had a brush with the self-help or the wellness community, the wellness space, which I'm assuming that you have considering you're listening to this podcast. someone somewhere at some stage has probably recommended that you journal or told you about how amazing journaling has been for them. Whether you took them up on that or not, whether you decided to give it a go, whether you saw the appeal, but you've just never been able to get into it.
我们总是说要相信你的闺蜜。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《相信闺蜜，宝贝》（trust the girlfriends. Trust me, babe）。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》（The psychology of your 20s），这是一个探讨我们二十岁时生活的一些重大改变与过渡，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到播客。无论你是新听友还是老听友，无论你身处世界何地。非常高兴你能来到这里收听另一期节目，当然，我们将一如既往地剖析、深入探讨、探索我们二十岁的心理。如果你曾经接触过自助群体或健康社区、健康领域——考虑到你在收听这个播客，我假设你肯定接触过——那么某个地方的某个人在某个阶段可能曾向你推荐过写日记，或者向你讲述过写日记对他们来说有多么神奇。无论你当时有没有采纳他们的建议，无论你决定尝试一下，还是看到了其中的吸引力，但你发现自己始终无法真正投入其中。
I think journaling is one of the holy grails of the wellness community, of the therapy community. It's one of the biggest pieces of advice that people like to give to others when they are stressed, when they are anxious, when they're grieving, heartbroken, even in good times, have you tried journaling? Why don't you journal about it? And what is the deal with this? Why is it so amazing to be able to write down your feelings? Why does it always come up in these discussions? Well, today, I want to talk about it by popular request, by popular demand from so many listeners. What is the magic behind journaling and how can we really embrace it? I am going to admit I'm one of those annoying people who has been journaling for years and who swears by it.
我认为写日记是健康社区和治疗社区的圣杯之一。这是人们在感到压力、焦虑、悲伤、心碎，甚至是生活顺遂时最喜欢给别人的建议之一：你试过写日记吗？你为什么不把这件事写进日记里呢？这到底是怎么回事？为什么把自己的感受写下来会这么神奇？为什么在这些讨论中总会出现这个话题？所以今天，应广大听众的强烈要求，我想来聊聊这个话题。写日记背后的魔力是什么，我们又该如何真正去拥抱它？我必须承认，我就是那种烦人的人，已经坚持写日记多年并且对它深信不疑。
I feel myself getting, I wouldn't say worse, but more detached from my life when I don't journal. And I definitely feel the quality of my experiences and my emotions improve when I do. Journaling for me makes me very present. It makes me more reflective of my life. I feel closer to my memories. I love it for so many reasons. but I also get that it's kind of hard to get into if it's not something that you're a regular at or that you have done very often or if it's not how you necessarily have tended to process
每当我不写日记时，我就会感到自己——不能说在变糟，但——与生活的疏离感更强了。而当我坚持写日记时，我绝对能感觉到我的经历和情绪质量都有所提升。对我来说，写日记让我活在当下。它让我对生活有了更多的反思。我觉得自己离记忆更近了。我出于种种原因而热爱它。但我也明白，如果这不是你习以为常的事情，或者不是你经常做的事情，亦或是这本来就不是你处理情绪的习惯方式，那么要上手确实有点难。
your emotions. Everyone that likes it really likes it but it's kind of like reading or any, you know, any hobby or exercising or eating healthy. We know we should be doing it. We know that we will feel better after doing it but there are always so many mental barriers. So many empty notebooks we promise to start writing in at the start of the year, so many times that we plan to journal in the evening and then we just never get around to it. So today, let's talk about the fundamentals and of course the psychology of journaling, why it helps our brains process trauma, why it helps our bodies heal faster, how it improves our intelligence, our friendships, our memories, but also more
每个人只要喜欢它，就会非常喜欢它；但这有点像读书，或者任何爱好、锻炼、健康饮食。我们知道自己应该去做。我们知道做完之后会感觉更好。但总会有那么多的心理障碍。年初时我们承诺要在里面写字的空白笔记本有那么多；我们无数次计划在晚上写日记，结果却总是没有付诸行动。所以今天，让我们来聊聊日记的基础知识，当然还有写日记的心理学——为什么它能帮助我们的大脑处理创伤，为什么它能帮助我们的身体更快地自愈，它是如何提升我们的智商、友情和记忆力的；但更重要的
importantly, how to actually make it an enjoyable practice and one that is actually useful rather than a chore, how to actually want to journal and where to even start. I'm going to give you the four fundamentals of journaling and how to actually enjoy journaling and some fun journal prompts and also really talk about some of the myths and misconceptions about this method and what it can actually do. our health and notice how I didn't just say mental health, our health on a holistic level, from physical to social to emotional, there is a lot to talk about. So without further ado, let's get into the psychology and the fundamentals of journaling.
更重要的是，如何真正让它成为一种享受，一个真正有用而不是苦差事的习惯，如何真正想要去写日记以及从哪里开始。我将为您介绍日记的四个基础，如何真正享受写日记，一些有趣的日记提示，并真正讨论关于这种方法的一些神话和误解以及它实际上能做什么。我们的健康，注意我说的不仅仅是心理健康，而是全方位的健康，从身体到社交再到情绪，有很多话题要聊。所以闲话少说，让我们进入日记的心理学和基础知识。
Journaling has a lot of different forms, you know, from the tried and tested notebook to a structured gratitude journal or a workbook, a blog. I don't know if the people still blog anymore, maybe an Instagram account even, your notes app, anything that causes you to express your thoughts in a written form outside the confines of your mind, to me that counts as journaling. I think we have a very narrow picture of what journaling looks like and it's a person at a desk writing page after page or, you know, a very Victorian image of a Bronte character with an ink and a quill penning very beautiful poetry.
日记有很多不同的形式，你知道的，从屡试不爽的笔记本，到结构化的感恩日记或工作簿、博客。我不知道现在人们是否还写博客，也许甚至是一个Instagram账号、你的备忘录App，任何能促使你将自己的思想以书面形式表达出来的东西，只要跳出了思维的局限，对我来说这就属于日记。我认为我们对日记长什么样有着非常狭隘的看法，觉得那是一个人坐在桌前一页接一页地写，或者（你知道的）是非常具有维多利亚时代风格的勃朗特小说人物形象，手里拿着墨水和鹅毛笔在写着非常优美的诗歌。
Not at all. Journaling can be as large or small as romantic or practical as you want it to be. And I think that's what makes it so incredible. It is just so accessible and cost effective. Anyone can do it in the way that works for them. It's kind of like what running is for our physical health.
完全不是这样。写日记可以像你希望的那样宏大或微小，浪漫或务实。我认为这正是它如此不可思议的地方。它非常平易近人且经济实惠。任何人都可以用适合自己的方式来做这件事。这有点像跑步对我们身体健康的作用。
If you have shoes and you have your legs, you can run. And if you have your brain and something to write on, you can journal and you'll feel better afterwards, hopefully, most likely. Some people like to just like pour their heart out every three months when they need it. There are people who, like I said, write a page or more every day. There is, you know, list form. There is naming what you're grateful for, what you, you know, what happened in your day, your highlights and low lights. There is the kind of journaling that is very structured and really keeps account of what you're going through day by day. My point here is that there are no rules. The only condition for journaling is that you're finding some way to record
如果你有鞋子，有双腿，你就可以跑步。如果你有大脑和可以写字的东西，你就可以写日记，而且写完之后你会感觉更好——希望如此，大概率是这样。有些人喜欢每隔三个月在需要的时候倾诉一下。也有人像我说的，每天写一页或更多。还有（你知道的）列表形式。有记录你感激什么的，记录你一天中发生了什么、高光时刻和低谷时刻。还有那种结构非常清晰、真正记录你日复一日经历的日记。我的观点是，这里没有规则。写日记唯一的条件就是你要找到某种方式来记录
your personal thoughts, your feelings, insights, troubles, or daily life. And the final condition, maybe not even a condition, maybe not even a rule, but the beauty of journaling is that it doesn't even need to be good. That's another thing that I think sometimes holds us back from writing or saying that we are someone who journals. When we put something on a page or we put it down in writing, it feels so permanent and so sacred. And I don't know if it's just me, but we can't help but picture someone reading it back maybe in the future and getting to essentially peer directly into our lives. So sometimes we fixate on making it worth it. We fixate on it sounding good or using our neatest handwriting or not coming off as to, I don't know, to anything, not coming off as
你的个人想法、感受、见解、烦恼或日常生活。最后一个条件——也许甚至算不上条件，也许甚至不是一条规则，但写日记的美妙之处在于，它甚至不需要写得好。这是我认为有时会阻碍我们动笔，或者阻碍我们承认自己是个会写日记的人的另一个原因。当我们把一些东西写在纸上，或者落笔成文时，它感觉是如此的永久和神圣。我不知道是不是只有我这样，但我们总是忍不住去想象未来可能会有人读到它，并且能够直接窥探我们的生活。所以有时我们会执着于让它物有所值。我们执着于让它听起来很完美，或者使用最整洁的字迹，又或者在自己的日记中表现得不那么……我不知道，不那么……表现得不要
too loud or too emotional, too sensitive in our own journal entries. But the thing is, is that journaling is strictly for you. There are no mistakes. There are no bad entries except for the ones that weren't written. There are no wrong thoughts. You know, no one is going to give you a mark like it's an assignment. As I said before, journaling is a self-care, self-love practice. It's one of the only times that everything gets to be about you and you get to do it in the way that works best as long as you are doing it. Journaling has an amazing reputation when it comes to, I guess, healing some of our biggest emotional afflictions, whether that is helping us with anxiety and depression or grief or even just managing everyday stresses. I don't even think I would be able to count the number
太张扬、太情绪化、太敏感。但事实是，写日记纯粹是为你自己服务的。这里没有错误。也没有糟糕的日记，除了那些压根没有动笔的。也没有错误的思想。你知道的，没有人会像批改作业那样给你打分。正如我之前所说，写日记是一种自我关爱、自我疗愈的实践。这是仅有的几个时刻，一切都以你为主，而且你可以用最适合你的方式去做，只要你去做就行了。在疗愈我们最大的一些情感创伤方面，无论是帮助我们应对焦虑和抑郁、悲伤，还是仅仅管理日常压力，日记都有着极佳的声誉。我甚至觉得我数不清有多少
of therapists that have been, or have said to me, oh, have you tried journaling? Have you tried writing about these feelings? Have you tried articulating them in written form? What exactly is so powerful about that though because anyone can pick up a piece of paper and a pen and write about how they're feeling, right? What is the big secret here? Well, let's talk about it. Starting with the science and the evidence, of course, because we're not going to be making any claims without some proof. Journaling has basically been proven to have everything from psychological to even physical benefits, which may surprise some of us. It definitely surprised me and we'll get to why in a second, but starting with the more psychological side. The moment when I think people really began to
治疗师曾经问过我，或者对我说过：“哦，你试过写日记吗？你试过把这些感受写下来吗？你试过用文字把它们表达出来吗？”不过，这到底有什么强大的地方呢？因为任何人都可以拿起纸和笔，写下自己的感受，对吧？这里面有什么惊天大秘密吗？好吧，让我们来聊聊这个。当然，从科学和证据开始，因为我们不会在没有任何证据的情况下做出任何断言。基本上已经证明，写日记不仅有心理益处，甚至还有生理益处，这可能会让其中的一些人感到惊讶。这绝对让我感到惊讶，我们一会儿就会讲到原因，但还是先从比较心理学的一面开始讲起吧。我认为人们真正开始
recognize the benefits of this was from a landmark study in 1988. And in this study, students were randomly assigned to write about either very traumatic experiences or very superficial topics for four days in a row. Six weeks later, those who had delved into traumatic experiences, who had really written pages and pages about how they felt, the meaning they applied, how it impacted their life, they actually reported feeling a lot better. They reported more positive moods, lesser anxiety, fewer illnesses than those who were writing about everyday experiences. This is when journaling really began to be recommended more.
认识到这一好处的时刻，源于1988年的一项具有里程碑意义的研究。在这项研究中，学生们被随机指派连续四天写非常具创伤性的经历或非常肤浅的话题。六周后，那些深入探讨过创伤经历、真正写了厚厚好几页关于自己感受的人——包括他们赋予的意义以及这件事如何影响了他们的生活——实际上报告说他们感觉好多了。与那些只写日常经历的人相比，他们报告了更积极的情绪、更少的焦虑以及更少的疾病。正是在这个时候，写日记开始被更多地推荐。
I'm sure when this study was first proposed, back in the 80s, people were like, you want to measure whether writing something down is good for people. But after this study was published, I think it kind of said something that everyone was already thinking. When you actually find an outlet for what is going on in your brain and the kind of emotional and cognitive affliction that your problems are causing you, the mental strain, I guess when you find an outlet for that, you feel better. And I think that was one of the first times that people had put that into words. People had been obviously writing journal entries and poetry and novels and stories
我敢肯定，当这项研究在80年代首次被提出时，人们会想：你想衡量写下某些东西对人们是否有益。但在这项研究发表之后，我认为它说出了一种每个人心里其实都已经想到了的东西。当你真正为大脑中正在发生的事情、你的问题所带来的情感与认知折磨（这种精神压力）找到一个宣泄口时，我想，当你为之找到一个宣泄口时，你会感觉好一些。我认为这是人们第一次用语言把这一点表达出来。显然，自从有人类存在以来，人们就一直在写日记、诗歌、小说和故事
for as long as humans had existed. But this study was when someone really said, hey, no, this actually has a really positive impact on mental health. And people started recommending it. They were basically like, oh, I better get on board. This is such a cost-effective method of making people feel better. Since then, it's become a huge topic of conversation. And so many more studies have been produced around that.
但这项研究是第一次有人真正说：嘿，不，这实际上对心理健康有着非常积极的影响。于是人们开始推荐它。他们基本上就像是：哦，我最好也加入进来。这是一种让人们感觉好起来的、极具成本效益的方法。从那以后，它成为了一个巨大的对话话题。围绕这个话题，又诞生了更多类似的研究。
One of my favorite ones is a study that shows that people who journal regularly, twice a week, recover from heartbreak faster than those who don't, sometimes even twice as fast. That was one of the estimates. even by the researchers, I don't know if you can really, you know, measure how far someone gets over heartbreak, but there you go. There was another study published only a couple years ago that said journaling for 15 minutes a day can increase our IQ, our literal intelligence, and also our EQ, which is our emotional intelligence. That makes you a better friend. That makes you a better partner, a better coworker, more in touch with your own emotions, of course, but also more in tune.
我最喜欢的研究之一表明，经常写日记（一周两次）的人从失恋中恢复的速度比不写日记的人更快，有时甚至快两倍。这是当时的估计之一。甚至连研究人员也这么说，我不知道你是否真的能（你知道的）衡量一个人走出失恋有多远，但事实就是如此。几年前发表的另一项研究表明，每天写日记15分钟可以提高我们的智商——字面意义上的智商，以及我们的情商（EQ），也就是情绪智商。这能让你成为一个更好的朋友。这能让你成为更好的伴侣、更好的同事，当然也会让你更懂自己的情绪，同时也能更好地体察
therefore empathetic to others. This stuff, I think we all know. Writing about your feelings makes you understand them better, which means you understand yourself better, but also others, people who are also members of the human race. That's fairly simple. But when we start looking at the physical health benefits,
并因此对他人产生同理心。我认为这些东西我们大家都懂。写下你的感受能让你更好地理解它们，这意味着你能更好地了解自己，同时也能更好地了解他人，也就是同为人类的其他成员。这相当简单。但是，当我们开始关注生理健康方面的益处时，
that's when it really starts to get so interesting and almost a little bit insane for me. And the case for journaling just becomes even greater. So let me tell you about a pretty amazing New Zealand study from 2013, which basically showed, maybe not showed, basically suggested that writing helped our body heal itself faster from physical injury. So it's not just that it helps people recover from trauma or become more intelligent or feel less stressed.
情况就开始变得非常有趣，甚至对我来说有点不可思议了。而且，支持写日记的理由也变得更加充分了。所以，让我来向大家介绍一项来自2013年的非常了不起的新西兰研究，该研究基本上表明——也许不能说显示，基本上暗示了写作有助于我们的身体从身体伤害中更快地自我愈合。所以，它不仅能帮助人们从创伤中恢复、变得更聪明或减轻压力，
It has physical healing properties. So in this study, 49 healthy adults aged. 64 to 97, they wrote about either a really upsetting event or just their daily activities for 20 minutes. After two weeks had passed to make sure that, you know, any initial negative feelings stirred up by recalling those upsetting events had passed. All the subjects had a biopsy on their arm, basically meaning that a piece of tissue was removed from their arm. They had a small wound. That wound was then photographed for the next 21 days while the group continued to keep journaling about either upsetting events or everyday events. On the 11th day, 76% of the group that did expressive writing had fully healed, with 42% of the control group having healed. So 42 versus 76%. How is that not talked about more? That is something.
它还具有身体愈合的特性。在这项研究中，49名64至97岁的健康成年人被要求写20分钟，内容要么是关于一件真正令人心烦的事件，要么仅仅是他们的日常活动。两周过去后，为了确保（你知道的）由回忆那些令人心烦的事件所激起的任何最初的负面情绪已经消退，所有受试者都在手臂上做了一个活检，基本上意味着从手臂上取下一小块组织。他们留下了一个小伤口。在接下来的21天里，这个伤口被拍了照片，而这组人则继续写日记，记录令人心烦的事件或日常生活。到了第11天，进行表达性写作的那一组人中有76%已经完全康复，而对照组的康复比例为42%。所以是42%对比76%。怎么会没有人多谈谈这个呢？这可真是一件
an astonishing study. Obviously, small sample size, it would definitely need to be replicated, but if you think that study was just a fluke, after it was released, even before, people were really looking into this. And there was another study that appeared in the journal of the American Medical Association, so not a small journal, and it looked at patients with asthma and arthritis. half of who were again asked to write for 20 minutes each day about something that was bothering them, a stressor, a past trauma, and the other half who were asked to just write about their daily life. Four months later, the patients in the stressful writing group showed increased improvement on objective clinical evaluations about their symptoms of asthma, arthritis and emotional distress.
了不起的研究。显然，样本量很小，绝对需要进行重复验证；但如果你觉得那项研究只是个巧合——在该研究发布之后甚至在此之前，人们其实一直在深入研究这个课题。另一项研究发表在《美国医学会杂志》（Journal of the American Medical Association）上，可见这不是什么小刊物，它研究了哮喘和关节炎患者。其中一半的人再次被要求每天花20分钟写下困扰他们的事情、压力源或过去的创伤，而另一半人则被要求只写他们的日常生活。四个月后，进行压力写作的那组患者在关于其哮喘、关节炎和情绪困扰症状的客观临床评估中显示出更大的改善。
They were less stressed, they had fewer negative symptoms of their asthma, and their situation, their condition has had deteriorated less. So the research has basically concluded writing about something that was stressing them out, really engaging their emotions through this practice, not only helped these patients get better in a sense, but it also kept them from getting worse. Why is this the case? How is it possible that writing could heal a wound,
他们的压力更小了，哮喘的负面症状更少了，并且他们的情况、病情恶化得更慢了。因此，研究基本上得出结论：写下让他们感到压力的事情，通过这种练习真正地投入他们的情感，不仅在某种程度上帮助这些患者好转，还阻止了他们病情恶化。为什么会这样呢？写作怎么可能治愈伤口、
minimize a chronic illness. And I want to obviously just state here that we're not trying to, I'm not trying to claim that journaling is going to replace modern medicine and magically everyone will get better. But what it really comes down to in all of these instances is stress. Stress kills our cells. Stress reduces our immune system functioning. Stress shortens our life expectancy. It puts our body under strain. All of these things obviously have a very big physical impact and can contribute to pre-existing illness or make us more susceptible to new illness. But controlling our stress, that helps control the physical burden placed on our body. And that is why journaling is shown to have these really wonderful, if not unbelievable,
减轻慢性疾病。当然，我在这里只想说明，我们并不是要——我并不是想声称写日记将取代现代医学，并神奇地让所有人的病都好起来。但在所有这些情况下，真正起作用的核心其实是压力。压力会杀死我们的细胞。压力会削减我们的免疫系统功能。压力会缩短我们的预期寿命。它让我们的身体承受压力。所有这些事情显然都会对身体产生非常大的影响，并可能导致原有的疾病或者使我们更容易感染新的疾病。但是控制我们的压力，有助于控制施加在我们身体上的生理负担。这就是为什么日记被证明具有这些非常奇妙的——如果不是令人难以置信的话——
healing properties for physical, not just mental ailments, because it basically gets our brain to process heavy emotions and experiences that would otherwise manifest in physical tension and physical turmoil. I think it's just one of the many ways that our mind and our body interact and impact each other. And I think we don't explore that enough, especially in Western medicine. We're so focused on treating symptoms rather than holistically really thinking about the body and thinking about the mind and how our psychology and our emotional state contributes to how how we're basically functioning. The reason that I think journaling is so effective at managing stress or processing an emotion,
对生理（而不仅仅是心理）疾病的治愈特性的原因，因为它基本上让我们的大脑去处理那些沉重的情绪和经历，否则这些情绪和经历就会转化为身体的紧张和心理的动荡。我认为这只是我们的心灵和身体相互作用并相互影响的众多方式之一。而且我认为我们对此探讨得还不够，尤其是在西方医学中。我们太专注于治疗症状，而不是从整体上去真正思考身体、思考心灵，以及我们的心理和情绪状态如何影响我们的基本机能。我认为写日记之所以在管理压力或处理情绪方面如此有效，
any emotion, is that it's an essentially, you know, an organizational system. It's an organizational procedure. It's a way of cleaning things up or making sense of things that we can't work out by just thinking about them over and over again. That's the curse of overthinking, something that I'm sure we all do from time to time. It leads us to believe that we are problem solving when actually we are just making the issue more convoluted and getting further into the labyrinth. And writing about it does something about the thoughts. And it kind of keeps track of where we've been, but also at a very basic level, it's a circuit breaker.
任何情绪，是因为它本质上是一个（你知道的）组织系统。它是一个组织程序。它是一种清理思绪或理清头绪的方法，而这些是我们单靠一遍又一遍地思考无法解决的。这就是过度思考的诅咒，我相信我们大家偶尔都会这样做。它让我们误以为自己在解决问题，而实际上我们只是把问题弄得更加复杂，并在迷宫里越陷越深。而把事情写下来，会对这些想法产生某种作用。它有点像在追踪我们走过的路，但同时在非常基础的层面上，它是一个断路器。
Generally gets us out of our mind. It kind of removes us from the problem and allows us to write about it, not. in the third person, but almost in a more detached way. We have some form of emotional distance that we don't get when we try and process all of our feelings about a situation, all of our heavy emotions in our brain alone. The more we practice journaling, obviously in a moment, it can just help us really break away from, you know, going over and over unnecessary details, not being able to find an exit to our thoughts, but the more we practice it, the more it becomes a tool to reprogram maladaptive thoughts, to reflect and remember our lives more realistically, to actually
通常能让我们跳出思维的局限。它在某种程度上把我们从问题中抽离出来，让我们能够去书写它，而不是。以第三人称，而是几乎以一种更超然的方式。我们获得了一定程度的情感距离，这是当我们试图在脑海中独自处理关于某种情况的所有感受、所有沉重情绪时所无法获得的。我们练习写日记的次数越多，显然在当下，它就越能真正帮助我们摆脱（你知道的）一遍又一遍地琢磨不必要的细节、找不到思维出口的状态；但我们练习得越多，它就越能成为一种工具，用来重塑适应不良的想法，更现实地反思和铭记我们的生活，从而真正
be able to look back at journal entries and be like, oh no, maybe my thoughts about that situation were wrong. This is how I remember it at the time. And it helps us organize our life and our thoughts and provide emotional catharsis. That was one of my favorite words, catharsis, when we really need it. You know, like, this thing is bothering me, this breakup, this heartache, this assignment, this moment when I embarrass myself, let me really spend time trying to think about this in a way that my brain normally wouldn't think about it by writing about it. And I'm not looking for a solution.
能够回过头来看日记，然后说：“哦，不，我对当时那种情况的想法可能错了。这是我当时记忆中的样子。”它帮助我们整理生活和思绪，并提供情感宣泄。这是我最喜欢的词之一，宣泄（catharsis），当我们真正需要它的时候。你知道的，就像：“这件事在烦扰我，这场分手、这份心碎、这个任务、这个让我感到尴尬的时刻，让我花点时间试着通过书写，以一种我的大脑通常不会采用的方式来思考它。”我不是在寻找解决方案。
I'm not journaling to find an answer. I'm journaling just to process what I've been through. And that is something that we don't always do because we are too stuck in our feelings to really detach from them and distance ourselves from them for a moment and just think about the situation in the grandest scheme of things.
我写日记不是为了找到答案。我写日记只是为了处理我所经历的事情。而这正是我们并不总是能做到的事情，因为我们太深陷于自己的情绪中，以至于无法真正从情绪中抽离出来，让自己暂时与它们保持距离，从而从最宏观的角度去思考局势。
So basically what I'm trying to say in the most convoluted way possible, journaling is valuable and helps us deal with stress and distress because it forces you to put complicated emotions about your future, about your family, your friends, your trauma, your day, whatever it may be. It forces you to put those complicated emotions into some form of coherent sentence or paragraph. And through that act, you get more clarity and you feel like you're getting somewhere. Everything else that comes along with that is basically a benefit of not being consumed with over-analizing
所以，基本上我想用最曲折的方式表达的是：写日记之所以有价值，并且能帮助我们应对压力和痛苦，是因为它迫使你将关于你的未来、你的家庭、你的朋友、你的创伤、你的一天（无论可能是什么）的复杂情绪，变成某种形式的连贯句子或段落。通过这一行为，你获得了更多的清晰感，并且觉得你正在取得进展。伴随而来的所有其他事情，基本上都是不再沉溺于过度分析
and overthinking a problem. We have more space to begin to think about others, to really listen to them, to be curious. Our memory improves because we're not so caught up in ruminating. We sleep better. We enjoy life more. And that is what really helps us activate a better version of ourselves through journaling. I think it's not just that we are writing about something and somehow that makes everything feel a little bit less heavy. Yes, that's a component of it. But it's that we're using a new part of our brain, not just to problem solve, but to really go deeper, to apply meaning, to think about things in a different light. And here's the thing, it may be hard to start. It's really hard to find the time to feel motivated. But personally, I have never walked
和过度思考问题所带来的好处。我们有了更多的空间去开始思考他人、真正倾听他们、保持好奇心。我们的记忆力有所改善，因为我们不再那么深陷于反刍思维中。我们睡得更好。我们更享受生活。而这正是通过写日记帮助我们激活更好版本的自己的原因。我认为不仅是因为我们在写某些东西，并且不知为何这让一切感觉没有那么沉重了——是的，这是其中的一个组成部分。而是我们在运用大脑的一个新部分，不仅是为了解决问题，更是为了深入挖掘、赋予意义、以不同的视角来看待事物。而且情况是这样的，刚开始可能会很难。真的很难找到时间去感到有动力。但就我个人而言，我从来没有在写完——
away from writing, even just like a page or two, less than 500 words, and not felt better, not felt like something has been lifted. And I really, I don't think I'm not. I'm not. I don't think I'm the only one who has had that experience. Okay, I feel like I've gone on and on here about the benefits. Hopefully you're convinced, but being convinced is one thing. Actually doing the thing is a lot harder. Any of us could tell you that. So many of us want to be the person who journals. We want to have this catalog of our life and our feelings, but we feel like we don't have the time. We feel like we don't know where to start. We don't know what to write about. You know, taking 10 minutes to write about our feelings doesn't always feel as enjoyable immediately in the moment as the
哪怕只有一两页，少于500字——之后离开时感觉没有变好，没有感觉心头的大石卸下。而且真的，我不认为自己不是。我不是。我不认为只有我才有过这种经历。好吧，我觉得我在这里滔滔不绝地讲了很多关于好处的内容。希望你已经被说服了；但被说服是一回事，真正去付诸行动要难得多。我们中的任何人都可以告诉你这一点。我们有许多人都想成为那个会写日记的人。我们希望拥有这样一份记录我们生活和感受的目录，但我们觉得没有时间。我们觉得不知从何下手。我们不知道该写些什么。你知道的，花10分钟写下我们的感受，在当下并不总是像
instant gratification and pleasure that we get from our phones or from watching TV. That's how the fast dopamine of our entertainment cycle really works. Another barrier is perfectionism, you know, procrastination, boredom. It's kind of tiring sometimes to write all the time. But I'm going to stop us right there and kind of give you a hard truth. Life is full of excuses and there is an excuse for everything. You can go your whole life, which is taking the easiest route. But the thing about journaling is that it is such a small investment. It's basically free.
从手机或看电视中获得的即时满足感和快乐那样令人愉快。这就是我们的娱乐循环中快速多巴胺运作的方式。另一个障碍是完美主义，你知道的，拖延、无聊。有时候总是写字确实挺累人的。但我要在这里打住，并给你一个残酷的真相。生活充满了借口，对任何事情都有借口。你可以一辈子都选择最轻松的路线。但写日记的好处在于，它是一笔非常小的投资。它基本上是免费的。
It can take as little as five minutes. In a lot of those studies we just spoke of, people only journaled for 10 to 20 minutes. That's shorter than most TV episodes. And in comparison, the benefits are astounding. from a strictly, you know, like pro-cons perspective, there is no reason not to journal. The ratio of time and effort to breakthroughs and mental clarity is like one to two million. So how do we build this habit even when it feels difficult? Well, I've got you guys.
它只需短短五分钟。在我们刚才谈到的许多研究中，人们每天只需写10到20分钟的日记。这比大多数电视剧集还要短。相比之下，它的好处是惊人的。从严格的（你知道的）利弊角度来看，没有理由不写日记。时间和精力的投入与带来的突破和精神清晰度之间的比例简直是一比两百万。那么，即便在感觉困难的时候，我们又该如何建立这个习惯呢？好吧，我来罩着大家。
It's a message I get all the time from you. I always get people asking me about how to actually get into journaling. And I've thought about it a lot. So we're going to discuss the four secret ingredients or foundations to becoming a good journaler, how to make it feel not like a chore, how to actually be excited, and more importantly, how to actually integrate it into your identity and as part of who you are. We're going to talk about all of that and more after this short break. 2%.
这是我经常从你们那里收到的一条信息。总是有人问我如何真正开始写日记。我思考了很久。所以我们要讨论成为一个优秀的日记写作者的四个秘密要素或基础，如何让它感觉不像是一项杂务，如何真正感到兴奋，更重要的是，如何真正将它融入你的身份并成为你的一部分。在短暂的休息之后，我们将讨论所有这些以及更多内容。2%。
That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人数比例只有这么高。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看透健康产业中那些不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起发炎。我们弄错了。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the reasons. of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking, what the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett.
我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的原因。把自己投入一些艰难困苦中，你会成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即TWO percent，可在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（拍打）小金（Lil Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么，乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回溯过去》（Look Back at it）播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特（Sam Jett）。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过难关的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）一起畅谈80年代的快克（crack，一种可卡因）。澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不仅因为快克。我随时都可以聊聊快克，只是为了让你们大家知道。我的意思是，马克，到目前为止，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出这里有一条主线了。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病。
Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games.
谢谢你把那句话说完。是的。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《回溯过去》。欢迎收听我的新播客《艰难历程》（Learn the Hardway），我是主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。
And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase
为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太深陷于追逐之中，
that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it, and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Or are you a good person because you're afraid?
以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐，并且不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·ب恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross）。你觉得在地球上做一个好人重要吗？还是说你做一个好人只是因为你害怕？
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself.
因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。那是两种不同层面的信任。我希望你只是单纯地去做一个好人。加入我和凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）的行列，我们在我的新播客《艰难历程》中就治愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《艰难历程》，立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己
at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct? I doctored the test ones.
处于寻父丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露出她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达数年的法律诉讼，以证明真相。你曾两次篡改过这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。
It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。
The Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona.
吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我的天哪。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《爱情陷阱》（Love Trap）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被以欺诈罪起诉。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Whenever someone asked me on tips about how to get into journaling, how to really embrace it, how to enjoy it, I always give the same answer. And you guys know me, it's never a simple answer, but one that contains four parts. So let's break down these four tips I have from not only actually feeling excited to write and excited to journal, but getting something out of it, getting what you want out of it. So my first. tip is to, in the beginning, only journal when you really feel the need. Some people will say the easiest way to get into journaling or into anything is through routine and discipline and doing it
在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。每当有人向我讨教关于如何开始写日记、如何真正拥抱它、如何享受它的秘诀时，我总是给出同一个答案。大家了解我，这从来都不是一个简单的答案，而是包含四个部分的答案。所以让我们来剖析这四个建议，它们不仅能让你对写作和写日记感到兴奋，还能让你从中有所收获，得到你想要的东西。所以我的第一个
every day and staying consistent. You know, if you Googled how to start journaling, that is probably going to be one of the first tips that comes up. But making it a mission to journal every day just takes the fun out of it. And it's just another thing. on your to-do list. None of us want another thing on our to-do list, especially when I think that journaling should be something that you feel relieved, if not joyous, to be doing. So to start off, really journal when you feel like you have something to write about and journal as small or as big as you would like. It could be a single line, it could be something you've thought about or overheard. That is where you need to begin. Then go from there. When you get the hang of it and when
建议是，在刚开始时，只有在真正觉得有时，才去写日记。有些人会说，开始写日记或做任何事的捷径是通过规律、纪律，每天坚持，保持连贯。如果你在谷歌上搜索如何开始写日记，这很可能是最先跳出来的建议之一。但把每天写日记当成一项任务，就会抹杀其中的乐趣。这就成了你待办事项清单上的又一件差事。我们谁都不想待办事项清单上再多一件差事，尤其是当我认为写日记应该是一件让你感到解脱，甚至感到快乐的事情时。所以刚开始时，真的只是在觉得有话要写的时候再去写，而且写得可长可短，随你心意。它可以是一行字，可以是你思考过或无意中听到的话。这就是你需要开始的地方。然后从那里展开。当你掌握了窍门，并且
you find out what's important to you to journal about, that's when you really, I think, start to pick up momentum. So here's my evidence for this. Here's my reasoning. The researcher, who we spoke about before, who conducted that first groundbreaking study in the 80s on journaling, he basically said as much as what I just said. You don't need to journal every day. So his name is Dr. Penbaker, and he's basically the pioneer of writing therapy, as it was called. and he talks a lot about recovering from trauma through creative expression. And he said, and I quote, literally what I just said, I am not a big fan of journaling every day.
发现写日记对你来说什么才是重要的时，我认为你就会真正开始积蓄动力。所以我为此提供了证据。这是我的推理。我们之前谈到过的那位研究人员，他在80年代进行了关于日记的第一项具有突破性的研究，他基本上表达了和我刚才所说差不多的观点。你不需要每天都写日记。所以他的名字叫詹姆斯·佩恩贝克（Dr. Penbaker）博士，他基本上是写作疗法（正如当时所称的那样）的先驱。
The founder of writing therapy said that. And the reason he said that is because I will try and reframe how he said it. But one of the interesting things about journaling is actually sometimes writing too much, especially when you find yourself ruminating. And that's kind of one side of the point. write too much and you find yourself almost getting too over involved in the feelings associated with an event or when you're going through a really hard time and someone says or recommends that you journal you just don't feel like you can do it every every day so you don't do it at all.
写作疗法的创立者就是这么说的。他之所以这么说，是因为——我会试着重新组织一下他的话。但写日记有趣的地方在于，有时候写得太多，尤其是当你发现自己陷入反复思量时。这其实是问题的一个方面。写得太多，你会发现自己几乎过度卷入了与某个事件相关的情感中，或者当你经历非常艰难的时期时，如果有人说或建议你写日记，你只是觉得自己无法每天都坚持，所以索性就不写了。
So his recommendation is to think of journaling as like a life course correction as opposed to a really intense commitment or practice. The times that I always write the most is when I'm going through something really rough. You know, I think about my first ever heartbreak when I was 17, 18, I don't know, I filled like two notebooks in the span of six months with with bad poetry and endless teary passages about, you know, the meaning of life and love. And it's those moments in those times when you really need it that you should lean in. Think of journal. almost like a painkiller. You know, you don't take aspirin or Advil every day, at least I would hope not. You take it when you need it. And that is the premise of good journaling, I guess. Some people
因此，他的建议是将写日记看作是对生活路线的一种修正，而不是一种极其艰巨的承诺或练习。我写得最多的时期总是当我经历非常艰难的事情的时候。你知道，我想起我17岁、18岁时的第一次失恋，我不知道，我在六个月的时间里写满了两个笔记本，里面全是糟糕的诗句和无尽的、带着泪水的段落，关于生活和爱的意义。正是这些你真正需要它的时刻，你才应该全身心投入。把写日记几乎看作是一种止疼药。你知道的，你不会每天都吃阿司匹林或布洛芬，至少我希望你不会。你是在需要的时候才吃。我想，这就是好的写日记的前提。有些人
might really benefit from writing every day, but sometimes I can make it really tedious, right when, as Dr. Penbaker suggested, you need a life course correction. And a second component to this, when you feel the urge to journal or to write, especially at the beginning, please, please, please, just do it. Drop everything, anything that you're doing and put those thoughts that are basically begging to come out, put them down somewhere. That is the secret to any, to beginning, kind of any creative or expressive endeavor, not ignoring inspiration when it randomly emerges. Because sometimes that desire is not something that we can consciously call on. And so when we finally, you know, do get around to having the time to sit down and write in our routine way, in our, like,
可能真的会从每天写作中受益，但有时这会变得非常枯燥，正如彭贝克博士所建议的那样，你需要对人生轨迹进行修正。这其中的第二个要素是，当你感到有冲动去写日记或写作时，尤其是在一开始，请、请、请，马上去做。放下手头的一切，无论你在做什么，把那些基本上迫不及待想要表达的想法记录在某个地方。这就是任何、开始任何创造性或表达性尝试的秘诀，那就是不要忽视偶然出现的灵感。因为有时这种渴望并不是我们可以凭意识随叫随到的。所以当我们最终，你知道的，抽出时间坐下来，以常规的方式、以我们一天当中留出的时间去写作时，你知道，有时灵感已经消失了，然后就会觉得有点无趣。所以要抓住这些时刻，哪怕它们只有一瞬间，当你真的有一种想要写点什么出来的冲动时，哪怕只是在你的备忘录应用里，也要养成让它得以表达的习惯。这就引出了我的第二个建议。去尝试，找到适合你的方法。除此之外，试着让它变得有趣，或者找到一个原因、一个故事、一句名言，来激励你把写日记看作不仅仅是一项写作练习。所以我来进一步解释一下。首先，长话短说，因为我们之前谈过这个，每周手写长篇大论可能
time that we've put aside during our day to do it, you know, sometimes the inspiration is gone and then it just feels kind of boring. So take advantage of the moments, even if they're just a second when you really feel the urge to write something down, even if it's in your note app, notes app, just like get in the habit of letting that be expressed. And that kind of brings me to my second tip. Experiment and find what works for you. And beyond that, try and make it fun or find, you know, a reason, a story, a quote that motivates you to see journaling is more than just a writing exercise. So let me explain this a little bit further. Firstly and quickly, because we spoke about this before, but writing big entries by hand every week,
可能不适合你。相反，你可能会想要开启一个仅自己可见的Instagram账号，在上面发布照片、来自备忘录应用的截图，或者一本拼贴簿，甚至是一个垃圾日记。有些人把收据和图片贴在笔记本上，并在上面写写画画。这其实让我想起了前几天读到的一句话。让我把它找出来，因为它是如此优美，它对我来说完美地捕捉到了这一点。就是这个。如果你觉得自己不了解自己，我建议你准备一个笔记本，把所有东西都放进去。想法、你喜欢的名言、明信片、待办事项清单、日记条目、你最喜欢的歌、信件、干花、头脑风暴的零碎想法、感恩清单、便签、图片，字面意思上的所有东西。而在
not work for you. Instead, you may like, you know, want to start an Instagram that you keep private and you post photos or screenshots from your notes app or a scrapbook, even, a trash diary. Some people call them of receipts and pictures that you write on and stick them down into a notebook. That actually reminds me of a quote I read the other day. Let me pull it up because it's just so beautifully, it's just so beautifully captures this for me. Here it is. If you feel like you don't know yourself, I recommend keeping one notebook that you put everything in. Thoughts, quotes you like, call postcards, to do lists, diary entries, your favorite song, letters, dried flowers, brain dumps, gratitude lists, sticky notes, pictures, literally everything. And while in the process
填充这本日记的过程中，你会对你是谁、你喜欢什么、你的自我意识有一个感觉，尤其是当你几年后回过头来看，拥有了这样一本快照时。仅仅因为日记的既定形象是某种特定的样子，并不意味着。并不意味着你不能以其他方式进行表达，也不意味着你不能找到一种方式让它符合你表达情感的喜好，对吧？它不需要是一行接一行地打字。这是我非常坚持的一点。只要找到一种适合你的方式来写日记。
of filling this journal, you will get a sense of who you are, of all the things that you like, your sense of self, especially when you get to look back in a few years and you have this snapshot. Just because the image of journaling is one thing, it doesn't mean. It doesn't mean, you can't be expressive in other ways and that you can't find a way to make the suit how you like to express your emotions basically, right? Like it doesn't have to be typed line after line after line. And that is something that I really stand by. Just find a way to journal in a manner that suits you.
其次，找到你的动力。那句话的结尾让我深有同感，你知道的，想要为未来的自己留下一个快照的渴望。我明知需要却又不太想写日记时，其中一个主要原因，是因为我觉得将来回头去读这些旧日记会是一件多么有趣的事，
And secondly, find your reason. That really came up for me at the end of that quote, you know, the desire to have a snapshot for your future self. One of the big reasons I journal when I know I need to, but I don't really want to, is because I like to think about how interesting it's going to be to read back those old entries in the future
而且现在的我对15岁时的自己留下的记录有多么喜爱。而且，你知道，我经常在想，如果每次我有冲动写日记时都去做别的事，如果我没有花哪怕10分钟把笔放到纸上，我就不会有这样的机会。这不仅关乎我当下的感受、我的动力，或是我的无聊程度、写作灵感，
and how much present day me really enjoys looking at 15-year-old me's entries. And, you know, I often contemplate how I won't get that opportunity if every time I get the urge to journal, I just do something else. and if I don't just spend 10 minutes putting pen to paper. It's not just about how I'm feeling in the moment and my motivations or my level of boredom or inspiration to write,
还关乎我未来的自己能从中收获什么。前几天我和一个人聊天，她说，当写日记变得枯燥时，真正能启发她的是一想到自己的日记最终会被收进博物馆，或者当她离去后孩子们会去读这些日记，并在2084年阅读时，去了解2024年的二十多岁是什么感觉。所以，关于如何开始写日记，我的第二个建议是，好好想想你为什么要开始写日记，无论是纯粹为了心理健康的好处，还是能给这种习惯附加一个有趣的故事、有趣的意义，让它变得更
but also it becomes about what my future self is going to get out of it. And I spoke to someone the other day that said, you know, what really inspires her when journaling feels tedious, is thinking about her journals ending up in a museum or her kids reading them when she's gone and learning about how it felt to be in your 20s in 2024 when they're reading them in 2084. So that's my second instruction for getting into journaling is to really think about why you want to get into it, whether it is just purely the benefits for your mental health, or whether there's a fun story, a fun meaning that you can attach to the practice that makes it a little
浪漫或有吸引力一些，我是这么认为的。好了，接下来谈谈我关于优秀日记的第三个基础、核心要素，让别人替你完成最初的思考，尤其是在刚开始的阶段。你可以通过使用日记提示、购买结构化的日记本、在网上寻找灵感来实现这一点。开始任何事情最大的障碍之一，就是对我们认为一开始需要付出多少精力的预期。这会让开始变得困难得多。如果你不习惯写下自己的感受，不习惯进入那种反思的空间，并且觉得这令人生畏，那就顺着别人可能正在做的方式来做，让自己轻松一点。
bit more romantic, I would say, or glamorous. Okay, moving on to my third foundation, fundamental for. good journaling, let someone else do the initial thinking for you, especially in the beginning stages. And the way that you can do that is by using journal prompts, by purchasing a structured journal, looking for inspiration online. One of the biggest barriers to starting anything is the anticipation around how much effort we think will go into it to begin with. And that makes it so much harder to start. If you're not accustomed to writing down what you're feeling to entering that reflective space and you're finding it daunting, make it easier for yourself by following how other
我用过最喜欢的日记本之一是一个“五分钟感恩日记”，它在几年前非常非常受欢迎。还有一个例子是什么？比如，它们有那种“一天一句”、“一天一页”的书籍，这种结构化的日记本省去了思考的麻烦。你有一个可以用来书写的格式。你知道，我在努力回想感恩日记的结构是怎样的。我想它有四个部分。你需要写的全部内容就是：你那天感恩什么？你那天享受了什么？一些积极的肯定，以及你那天学到了什么，这让事情变得如此简单，而且这样做仍然蕴含着深刻的知识财富，这是一个非常棒的起点。我最喜欢的日记提示每次都对我很有用，
people may be doing it. One of my favorite journals I have ever used was a five-minute gratitude journal that was, it was really, really popular a few years back. And what was another example? Like, they had these one sentence a day, one page a day, books, these kind of structured journals take the thinking out of it. You have like a format upon which to write in. You know, I'm trying to think about what the gratitude journal was structured at as. I think it was, it had four sections. It was, all you had to say was, what are you grateful for that day? What did you enjoy that day? Some positive affirmations and what you learned that day and it made it so easy and there's still like a depth and wealth of knowledge in doing that and it's a really great place to start some of my favorite journal prompts that work
包括列出我感恩的五件事，如果我想的话我可以展开写，或者就保持这种列表的形式。我喜欢的另一个提示是关于写下脑海中重压着我的三件事的头脑风暴。这些方法的美妙之处在于，你可以随心所欲地把它们写得或长或短。就像我一开始说的，你想让它为你所用。你可不想让这感觉像是一件苦差事或者变得枯燥。还有一本书叫《500个日记提示》。作者是罗伯特·达夫，他是一位，我想他是一位精神科医生。
every time for me include just five things that I'm grateful for and I can expand if I feel like it or I can keep it in that list format another one that I love is just writing about just doing a brain dump about three things that are really weighing heavy on my mind and the beauty of these is that you can make them as short or as long as you like. And like I said in the beginning, you want to make it work for you. You don't want this to feel like a chore or like it's tedious. There is also a book called 500 journal prompts. It's by Robert Duff, who's a, I think he's a psychiatrist.
这本书太棒了。有些问题太棒了，而且非常独特。你只需挑一个，然后对此进行反思。我最喜欢的一些问题比如：你最喜欢的一次失败是什么？多么棒的一个日记提示啊。或者其中一个是：写下你和你的朋友是怎么成为朋友的故事。就像你和你最好的朋友是怎么成为朋友的那样。非常有反思性，它能引发你思考很多事情。
And it's amazing. Some of the questions are so good and they're so unique. And you just pick one and you reflect on that. Some of my favorites were like, what is your favorite failure? What a great journal prompt that is. Or one of them was like, write me the story of how you and your friend became friends. Like how you and your best friend became friends. Really reflective it makes you think about so many things.
我在想还有哪些。其中一个问题是：你最害怕知道答案的问题是什么？哪首歌带给你最生动的记忆？在你刚开始接触时，你只需一周做一次。这是一个下午的活动，一个自我护理的活动。你想写多久就写多久，想写多少就写多少。这可能有点不相关，但注意我是怎么说的，在下午做这件事。这是一个很随意的建议，但千万不要在睡前写日记，或者不要说你打算在睡前写日记，因为十有八九你最后都不会去做，而且你会分心或者直接睡着。
I'm trying to think some others. One of them was like, what is a question that you were really scared to know the answer to? Which songs have the most vivid memories for you? And you just do one a week as you're getting. into it. It's an afternoon activity. It's a self-care activity. And you just write for as long or as little as you want. This is kind of unrelated, but note how I said, do it in the afternoon. This is such a random tip, but just don't journal before bed or don't say that you're going to journal before bed, because you will eight out of ten times not end up doing it and you will get
所以，请在早上或下午过半的时候选择你的提示，然后当你有时间的时候抽出那一刻来写，而不是在睡前。我知道想要那样做的冲动是很自然的，对吧？就像我们在最具反思性的时候，也是我们拥有最多空闲时间的时候。但如果你真的想把写日记作为一种心理健康或情感锻炼融入生活，试着找一个你实际上更清醒、更当下的时间。所以，我的四个要素中的最后一个是：快速书写，不加评判。
distracted or you will fall asleep. So choose your prompt in the morning or in the mid-afternoon and then find that moment when you have a moment, not before bed. I know it feels like the urge to do that is a natural one, right? It's like when we're most reflective, it's when we have the most free time. But if you really want to integrate journaling as like a mental health or an emotional practice for you, try and find a time when you're actually a bit more conscious and a bit more present. So my final of the four ingredients write quickly and without judgment.
我把这个留到最后，但它可能配得上这个列表的第一位。我发现想要写日记的人面临的最大障碍之一，不是时间，因为我们都有时间，而是完美主义。是完美主义。是陷入我们自己的思维怪圈。当我们快速书写，不担心是否简明扼要，而只是尽可能多地把内容写在纸上时，我们就没有那么多时间去担心我们的表现如何。我们不用担心这是否是我们想表达的准确方式，我们想用的词是否完美，因为这并不重要。现在这里没有观众。没有——我已经说过很多次了——没有最终评分。
I saved this for last, but it probably deserves to be first on this list. One of the biggest barriers I find for people who want to journal, it's not time, because we all have time, it's perfectionism. It's perfectionism. It's getting caught up in our own head. And when we write quick and we don't worry about being succinct, but just about getting as much on the page as possible, we have less time to worry about how we're coming off. We don't worry about whether that was exactly how we wanted to say it, how we wanted to word it because it doesn't matter. There is no audience right now. There is no, I've said there so many times, but there is no final grade.
我经常觉得，我们很多人最后一次大量写作的经历之一是在学校里。你知道，那可能是我们最后一次真正需要用笔和纸写下成千上万个字或几百个字的时候。所以这感觉很像是一项任务。但写日记是那种美妙的事情之一，即使在我们心中觉得自己写得很烂，这种简单的行动本身依然非常、非常好。事实上，我甚至觉得有时候写得烂更好，因为你不会全神贯注于评判自己的情绪。
I often think like one of the last times a lot of us write is when we're in school. You know, that's probably one of the last times we really had to write thousands of words or hundreds of words with a pen and paper. So it can feel very much like a task. But journaling is one of those beautiful things where the simple act of doing it even badly in our minds, is still really, really good. In fact, I actually think sometimes doing it badly is better because you aren't preoccupied with judging your emotions.
你只是让自己去感受并达到那种宣泄。而且我认为，当我们写得烂的时候，正是我们最能感受到表达和处理情绪的需求的时候，因为我们不是在等待完美的时机，也不是在等待我们认为能够把事情说得最好的那一刻，我们只是在写，只是在勇往直前。所以我们来对写日记的四个技巧、四个基本原则做一个小结。首先，以适合你的方式、在你有冲动时写日记，让它变得有趣、独特，为己所用，并为这种练习赋予更深层的意义。让别人替你完成思考，最后，快速书写。
You're just letting yourself feel and reach that catharsis. And I think when we journal badly is when we feel most in tune with the need to express and the need to process because we aren't waiting for the perfect time or we aren't waiting for when we think we're going to be able to say things the best way. we're just writing, we're just going for it. So let's do a little summary of the four tips to journaling, our four journaling fundamentals. Firstly, journal the way that works for you and when you feel the urge, make it fun, make it unique, make it work for you and find a deeper meaning to apply to the practice. Let someone else do the thinking for you and finally write
把它倾吐出来。没有完美主义，没有过度思考。我们在其他地方已经做得够多了。所以，无论以何种对你有效的方式。有一点需要记住。写日记真的是你能送给未来自己的最大礼物之一，因为时间过得非常非常快，有时我们并不擅长记住此时此刻的自己，对吧？也许我们觉得当下非常真实，但在两、三、五年后，我们会失去对二十出头、二十岁中期或二十岁末期自己的认知。这是我认为写日记真正赋予我们的最终福祉，那就是在写作时能够从内到外地了解自己。并不是每个人都能体验到这一点，我真的很感激自己坚持写了这么久的日记，因为我
fast. Just get it out. No perfectionism, no overthinking. We do that enough elsewhere. So in whatever form works for you. Something to remember. Journaling is honestly one of the biggest gifts that you can give your future self because time goes by really, really fast and sometimes we are not great at remembering who we are in this moment, right? We feel very present right now, maybe, but in like two, three, five years, we kind of lose the perspective of who we were in our early or our mid or our late 20s. And that is a final blessing that I think journaling really gives us is the ability to know us from the inside out at the time of writing. And not everyone gets to experience that something I'm really grateful that I have kept journals for so long because I have
有这样一条美丽的、我不知道，比如美丽的时间线，我自己的美丽家谱。我其实不知道该怎么解释。希望你能明白我的意思。就像我拥有这样一条美丽的时间线。我就说到这里吧。我这里有点词穷了。所以，是的，我最后只想说一件事。我知道我好像一直在谈论。
this like beautiful, I don't know, like beautiful timeline, this beautiful like family tree of myself. I don't really know how to explain it. Hopefully you're getting what I'm saying. Like I have this beautiful timeline. I'm going to land on that. I'm kind of like losing my words here. So yeah, I just want to say one final thing here. I know I feel like I've been talking about.
我仿佛加入了这个“日记邪教”。我就是那种喋喋不休、对它赞不绝口的人。但说实话，我想说的是，有时它对某些人来说就是不管用。这没关系。不是每个人处理、想象、表达和思考的方式都一样。你知道，例如，我有几个朋友非常需要身体上的释放，那是他们管理压力的方式，
I'm in this like cult of journaling. I'm one of those annoying people who won't shut up about it. But in all honesty, I do want to say sometimes it just doesn't work for certain people. And that is okay. Not everyone processes or imagines or or, articulates and thinks in the same way. You know, for example, I have friends who really need a physical release, and that's how they manage stress,
那也是他们处理情绪的方式，通过跑步和身体上的表达。我还有一些其他的朋友喜欢不那么烧脑的方式。你知道，他们喜欢艺术，或者喜欢交谈，而不是通过独自一人的方式来解决问题。所以无论是什么，选择你的毒药，或者说选择你的解药，如果写日记不管用，那也没关系。你知道，我已经给它盖上了我最高级别的金字招牌，
and that's how they process their emotions, is through running and through a physical expression. And some of my other friends like something less cerebral. You know, they like art, or they like talking rather than working through things in a solitary way. So whatever it is, pick your poison, pick your cure, I should say, if journaling doesn't work, that's fine. You know, I've given it my gold style of approval,
但有时它就是太枯燥了，对你来说就是不管用，而且你也没有什么话要说。我真正想让你做的是，找到你的表达方式，找到你的处理方式，找到你的宣泄途径，找到一种把你的脑海中所感受到的任何东西、所有东西都释放到你的环境中或某种物理形态中的方式。这就是所有这些表达方式的共同点，从身体上的到艺术上的，再到语言上的，
but sometimes it's just too boring and it just doesn't work for you and you don't have anything to say. What I really want you to do is just find your way of expressing, find your way of processing, find your catharsis, find a way of getting anything, everything that you're feeling out of your brain and into your environment or into some physical form. And that's what all those ways of expressing, from physical to artistic, to verbal have in common,
它把你的想法、感受和担忧从你的大脑中带到了公开的现实中。所以我作为最后的寄语想说这些，但我真的希望你有所收获。我希望这合你的胃口，让你日记写得更好，写得更多，或者，你知道，你写得更少但更有效率，并且你真正对它为什么如此有益有了一种深刻的理解，甚至包括你可能以前不知道的这种实践的历史。一如既往，如果你喜欢这一集，请在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你现在正在收听的任何平台上给我们一个五星好评。这确实对节目的成长很有帮助，也能帮我们接触到新的听众，这总是令人愉快的。如果你有节目建议，如果你只是想联系我，想聊天，如果你对这一集有什么感想，请随时在Instagram私信我：That Psychology podcast。和往常一样，我们不久后会再聊。在那之前，请注意安全，保持善良。
it gets the thoughts and the feelings and the worries out of your brain into the open. So I just want to say that as a final message, but I really do hope that you have learned something. I hope this was up your alley, that you journal better, that you journal more, or that, you know, you journal less, you journal more effectively, and that you really have kind of baby-grained and your appreciation for why it is so beneficial
请对你自己温柔一点。我们周五会带着另一集回归。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯。这个空间聚焦于黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他地方根本无法安全进行的坦诚对话，而你是与一个深谙此道的持证专业人士在交流。有多少男人带着一副铠甲生活。它向世界暗示，你可不是好惹的。
and even some of the history of this practice that you may not have known. As always, if you enjoyed this episode, please give us a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, whatever you are listening right now. It really does help the show grow and it helps us reach new people, which is always delightful. If you have an episode suggestion, if you just want to get in touch, if you want to chat, if you have feelings about this episode, please feel free to DM me at That Psychology podcast. And as always, we are going to talk soon. Until then, stay safe, stay kind.
仅仅因为你有这种能力并不意味着你就必须这么做，在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。2023年，美国广播公司《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，勒纳女士。对吗？我伪造了一次测试。
Please be gentle with yourself. And we will be back on Friday with another episode. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with.
这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男性。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·兰吉尼。我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节季的推进，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Lerner. Correct? I doctored the test ones.
在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了心理韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。
It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
也就是TWO%，在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约过后，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一档iHeart播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。
That's TWO%. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
这就是百分之二。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们采取了行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他会得到应有的惩罚。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 以及您获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个 iHeart 播客。保证由真人制作。本集还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。